un sommet assez inattendue à metz cet
après midi entre l'allemand schumacher
et le français battiston tout le monde
sait maintenant qu'il s'agit de joueurs
de football et que le sommet avait été
précédée d'une rencontre quelque peu
rugueuse ils ont sur une pelouse
espagnole jeudi dernier une image qui
avaient scandalisé tous les spectres et
les spectateurs parmi lesquels
d'ailleurs de nombreux allemands et bien
le gardien ouest allemand est allé à
canossa ou plutôt un metz pour faire un
monde honorable et présenté ses excuses
à patrick battiston dont on a appris
qu'il souffrait d'une fracture de la
deuxième vertèbre cervicale sans
déplacement
les journalistes étaient donc bien
entendu là pour le choc historique a
accepté de rencontrer harrach mc r c'est
pour la simple raison que je me suis
imaginé un petit peu son moral je crois
qu'il a été très sévèrement critiqué
pour son geste et je pense que
moralement c'est donc dû être set ça
dure pour lui donc c'est pour cette
raison qu'il a souhaité me rencontrer
et puis vous voulez également
s'expliquer de la raison 5 son attitude
sur le terrain soit qu'il voulait pas le
faire devant la presse allemande parce
qu'il voulait le faire d'abord devant
moi je vais vous donnez donc
sa version c'est à dire qu'au moment où
michel platini me donne la balle en
profondeur
ils me voient arriver très vite sur le
ballon il sait pertinemment que je vais
arriver le premier et dans son état de
cause on est dans son esprit je pense
que je vais l'aube et ceux qui ce que je
pensais exactement faire mais en fait il
a anticipé et au moment de la frappe
j'ai envoyé le ballon de côté et s'est
trouvé donc sans appui en l'air et donc
il a voulu éviter de me rencontrer avec
les genoux et les pieds en avant donc
c'est pour cette raison qui s'est
retournée et qu'il n'a pas pu freiner
son élan et bien pour moi il n'y a pas
de sentiment de l'agressivité n'est de
dire une certaine rancoeur je voulais
juste juste savoir quel est son rôle
était son état d'esprit pour quelles
raisons dont ils avaient des communes la
effet c'est tout voilà je ça me suffit
d'avoir discuté comme ça
doucement mais sûrement très joli tout
ça fâche marqué pour la circonstance en
a même avalé son célèbre flou même temps